What's your name?
Hazel.
What's your full name?
Hazel Grace Lancaster.
Why are you staring at me?
'Cause you're beautiful.
So, what's your story?
I was diagnosed when I was 13.
Your real story.
I am quite unextraordinary.
I reject that on the hand.
You know, Gus talks about you all the time.
We're just friends.
I hope you realize, you trying to keep your distance from me...
...in no way lessens my affection for you.
Gus, I'm a grenade.
One day, I'm gonna blow up,...
...and I'm gonna obliterate everything in my wake,...
...and I don't want to hurt you.
You don't get to choose if you get hurt in this world,...
...but you do have a say in who hurts you.
I am in love with you, Hazel Grace.
And I know that love is just to shout into the void and that oblivion is inevitable,...
...and I am in love with you.
All your efforts to keep me from you are gonna fail.
You gave me a forever within the numbered days,...
...and I can't tell you how thankful I am for our little infinity.
It's a good life, Hazel Grace.
Okay?
Okay.